you could trust them for the most part
before
but there was always because it was
always about if they're in control
then they can make sure you're getting
the narrative and it's like you're
getting the information is fine
is that anything outside of their
control was worrisome now
they've lost control that's why i think
the the good guys are winning
you know the like michael mouse was
saying this we did the show with alex
jones
this is why we know the good guys are
winning that these conversations can
happen or a conversation like this
because they are they are so desperate
these these political activists
these these authoritarian you know
anti-speech individuals
they're so desperate they're putting out
stories that are
so insanely obviously fake but
it's because they what do they do what
are the people are starting to realize
that trump actually does have legal
plans there may actually be evidence and
i'll tell you this
if they didn't do this story i'd have
thought trump was going to lose
because i've been saying for a long time
i think joe biden is very likely going
to be the next like
he's going to be the next president and
tim the headline got me
i read that on twitter i was like but
check it out yeah right but but listen
the fact that they would say something
so brazen
says to me somebody's scared like
because look so which i don't understand
is that these news outlets
not every single journalist is a
political activist but there are
political activists there
i'll give you a good example politico
wrote a story
in i think it was january of 2017 about
uh uh ukrainian meddling in the u.s
election and how the ukrainians were
desperate now that trump had won
to like make amends later on when this
became big news with the impeachment
politico ran another story claiming
there never was ukrainian
interference in the election which is
really strange because they were the
ones who reported it so are you going to
retract your they didn't retract
so politico is simultaneously running a
story saying ukrainians meddled and
we're trying to make amends with trump
and
ukrainians never meddle it's fake news
because the person who wrote the
the fake news that ukrainian meddling
was fake news is the activist
an individual who's got a contract with
msnbc writing a story that supports the
political narrative
so i'm not i'm not saying there's a
grand conspiracy where like it's
mockingbird and you know and the and the
the journalists were hired by the cia
i'm saying these people
get these jobs because they are
democrats they want democrats to win
and then they say i'm a journalist but
the democrats are always right but
operation mockingbird was a real thing
in the 70s and before when the cia would
hire and pay journalists to write
pro-american propaganda and for all we
know it's still going on they said they
stopped doing it
well if if i could even add for those
who remember during these times
let's not forget the new york times
pushed the iraq war either after we find
out that it was a quagmire then the new
york times comes out oh well maybe uh
it wasn't as bad as we thought and there
was no weapons of mass destruction like
come on you had editors pushing this
thing check this out pull this up from
politico
ukrainian efforts to sabotage trump
backfire
kiev officials are scrambling to make
amends with the president-elect after
quietly working to boost clinton
from january 11 2017. let's jump forward
a couple years
to november 8 2019. ukraine didn't
interfere in 2016
trump officials testified okay perhaps
the qualifier there is trump officials
testified so is politico now going to
retract their article and say we're bad
at what we do when we write fake news
they are not no
so either way these news organizations
are garbage
okay so the structural element here that
is leading us to this conclusion that
the cultural war
is not going to be over in this election
but yet
is going to persist on further is the
fact that we have no
national social cohesion and that comes
from the internet and social media
instead of one voice walter cronkite
telling everybody how to feel every
night what to think what the story is
one to many just like your professor to
the crowd like the preacher
to the to the audience to the flock now
we've got many speaking to many
creating narratives that fit with all of
our different genetic makeup and
backgrounds and histories
why would we all be ready for one
narrative i don't know now that there's
a million narratives
narratives make you feel good they make
you feel sane they make you feel like
you understand the world
they make you feel like you know who's
on your team that's how we join teams
is by having a common shared knowledge
a common uh imagined order in their mind
and that's a narrative and now
there's a million narratives there's
going to be a million tribes and there's
no cohesion so what do you think happens
after
everything we saw with these trump
supporters getting attacked if trump
does if let's let's say they nullify
this election 150 000
153 maybe they won't do it because what
do you do do you disenfranchise all
these voters because
i don't know i really don't know but
what the trump trump
campaign has said in their lawsuit is
injunction against certification because
of the air because of the discrepancies
because of the problems
only way you can do it so that's state
legislation um
imagine if pennsylvania and nevada are
now they can't be certified
joe biden drops down i think what is
that 31 electoral votes
trump still needs to find i think six to
knock
uh joe biden down under 270. one
more state and then what do you think
happens if trump does
it's not about it's not about all of
this evidence of voter fraud
a lot of trump supporters don't
understand there's certainly evidence
there's the sworn affidavits there's
like the weird mathematical anomalies
um i think the biggest evidence comes
from matt brainard when he found people
who changed their addresses but still
had voted or
nashon garrett who says i did not vote
that was that's like the best evidence
we have so far
they keep adding qualifiers to it though
substantial voter fraud
widespread voter fraud if you find a
marked bill
okay if you find if if there's a guy
walking on the street and he buys a
coffee with a marked hundred dollar bill
like it's got blue ink on it
you're gonna be like where'd you get
that we just had a bank robbery
now someone's trying to spend the money
from the robbed bank it's only one bill
out of the how many they stole
you're gonna get detained and asked for
questions you know and they're gonna
question you and try and find more
evidence
and maybe you stumbled upon it maybe it
flood of a car but they're gonna wanna
know why you had it so if we hear one
dude says i did not vote
well now we gotta go and figure out who
else maybe didn't vote investigate this
that's the thing this is an audit
basically what we're doing is a forensic
audit we're trying to take we're taking
a sample size
and then trying to see if we need to
take more action you just take a sample
you study it and if the percentages you
know say it's enough to to warrant
further action
you take further action so so that's how
it should be
like they brought up the the concept of
two different people who that president
trump said were dead that were not
and they were like see this never
happens but that doesn't go the other
way
actually it's worse than that if there
were two examples of people who said
that they didn't vote but they actually
got their ballots mailed in for them
they don't consider that they don't
have like an audit it's actually much
worse than that there was uh fleka's
uh oh yeah you guys don't like us he put
out this list of 10 000 people he says
are dead
so i think it was usa today i can't
remember which which organization did a
fact check
and they said we grabbed a sample of 30
or so you know
around 30 and went through to figure out
if these people were actually dead and
what we found was while we couldn't
contact every single one because they're
dead
maybe here's the best part they said we
were able to find that some of these
people
simply had the same name as their
parents or their their birthday was
entered wrong and in one instance one of
the voters was actually dead
so i'm like wait wait wait wait wait
out of 10 000 and find one okay divide
the ten thousand by thirty is that how
many dead voters actually voted
i could take that ten thousand into this
uh exactly this is when that so media
bros accidentally tell the truth yeah i
know well
it's it's framing if you tell me you did
a random audit and found one of the
thing one of the one of those actually
was really dead
doesn't that raise alarm bells yeah
turns out we grabbed a random sample and
actually found a dead voter
i read that and i'm like how how is it
that they glossed over that fact
well it's because most of the ones we
found were actually alive okay great
how about you do an audit of the full
ten thousand tell me how many dead
voters there are well it's like you said
great it's like you said in the past if
this happens even
one time this is something that we have
to consider and they like i said no
a bank gets robbed and then you see a
dude trying to spend a marked bill
you're going to be like hey buddy
where'd you get that
and then you might actually that you get
a warrant we're going to search your
vehicle because we saw that
you cop walks by he looks in the car and
he sees the bill
and then well you still got to get a
warrant for it but like let's see you go
to someone's house and they see in the
window there's you know a
blue ink on a shirt they're going to be
like that's evidence
it's a sign or indication that something
may be true they then get a war do an
investigation go in the house and hey
maybe they don't find anything maybe the
guy just bought blue ink because he
wanted to be like david cross from
wrestlemania or something
or maybe they go in and find big old
bags of cash
this is the craziest thing they keep
saying trump has found
has given no proof of widespread voter
fraud
did trump deploy like 300 000 federal
agents across the country to audit every
single election
no then of course you're not gonna find
that's that's the trick they do that's
that's the word play
trump has found evidence and even the
minor evidence presented like the nevada
poll workers had straight up this weird
thing happened where they came out of a
biden van had a box of bouts or
something and i said and she went on
laura ingram and said this
the guy naeson garrett sang i did not
vote those are
signs or indications that fraud has
occurred now we have to stop
send in the investigators to see if
there is widespread voter fraud
it makes you wonder when trump's legal
team got threatened into quitting you
saw this porter right i think it's
called porter wright and morris llp
were harassed by the lincoln project and
then like abruptly withdrew
from their case in pennsylvania they
were putting out the phone numbers and
email address of their lawyers
targeting their clients that's not
something honest actors do
if you think you're gonna win and trump
they keep saying trump's lawsuits are
frivolous and a waste of time what a
what a crazy waste
let them play out then why is the press
lying about them
and why are they attacking like
threatening and harassing the legal
teams that are that are filing these
suits
it's just and the list thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you